Iraqi woman standing together but not
standing alongside men this is how the
leading Shia cleric moqtada al-sadr says
Iraqis should protest against government
corruption high unemployment and US
troops base team mockery Sadr is not
against women protesting but he is
against some illegitimate acts that
happen in the protest camps asada says
protests should be segregated he tweeted
that demonstrations have become mired in
nudity promiscuity drunkenness and drug
use some of our sadhus female supporters
on this march in Baghdad Sattar city
agree we've been protesting since
October with our sons and brothers but
according to the waste accepted by Islam
we protest and create our revolution but
within limits and values which are
accepted by our religion al Sadr LED
armed groups against US forces during
the 2003 Iraq war now he leads a shear
political bloc in Iraq's Parliament he
first backed anti-government rallies
when they reignited in October but when
demonstrators refused to accept Mohammed
Allah we are Saudis favored to succeed
the current prime minister Adel Abdel
Mukti al Sadr stopped supporting the
anti-government protests his
paramilitary forces are accused of
turning on the protesters they were
originally protecting asados demand for
gender segregation in protests was
largely ignored in rallies in Baghdad on
Thursday by men and women who marched
together after his last tweet we thought
it was positive because no one responded
to it all the people see segregation
between genders as an old idea which
leads to more problems and submissions
several weeks ago moqtada al-sadr called
for a Million Man March but the numbers
which turned up to that when anything
like what he'd hoped for the numbers on
protests generally have been dwindling
since they began back in October but
people are going to be watching very
carefully about the numbers who turn up
at this protest in case it might give
some sort of indication about whether or
not the Shia clerics influence in Iraq
is changing men and woman who protest in
Iraq say they share a common purpose in
opposing the government and demanding
change but they seem divided about how
they should make their voices heard Rob
Matheson al-jazeera Baghdad